welcome to this video mega Ozzie debt
yeah this is a strong GM Zhang ones ow
completely screwing that one up from
Australia and I have one out of five
against him that's not good okay maybe
let's try to have some funny with the
Kings inion okay sometimes the my white
player has the [ __ ] is it yet but it
leads to entertaining games very often
so let's try this that looks a bit
strange but I want to go if 510 e5 later
and asking white what is movies yeah
exactly very often if you play with them
with e 5 you want to have g 4n but like
it sometimes delaying 'if I've just to
UM to ask wide ok really want to play G
form and in this case you said yes I
want to play g4 even if you are not
committed to going if I've and this is
actually quite nice for Wyatt I mean
what nice now it's a it's a very very
decent line I have played this this
opening variation myself with white ok
so let's see the black problem is i mean
the nice thing for blankets that he has
some yeah he has some weaknesses here
with HCG for that he might play against
butts plaxton has little space and this
is a typical problem of this maroc see
buying structures if i go nitey six here
takes takes a high f might be an idea
but ok he cannot really easily take on
b7 I've worked b8 be too not sure that
looks a bit mistimed
okay so he does not want to trade very
typical strategy and it's not clear if
my night is so great yeah that's
definitely true okay maybe play a 5-4
some space there okay so g5 might come
true
they have have a bit very very typical
problem yeah I have little space and too
many pieces i would like to trade some
pieces now okay mg5 i have to go to the
eighth nomad not much that I can do I
really have to put this on c6 otherwise
I don't see how I get stuff developed
him so this is at least okay here he has
maybe fy5 yeah just brutally pushing him
damn thats its that's the way to go I
tried to get in Queen a five and tonight
c5 and Queen a 5 a 3 I would be ideal
but he won't allow that I think at five
he can play it but it is also very
committal f 595 okay that's also good
probably Jim not very happy with the
idea of taking that but what is what
else I can do this okay I can do this
for six maybe
yeah is six however is weakening that is
clear ok let's take now and then queen a
five well it's not so bad me I mean I'm
not like in 2d astok about this position
but it i think it is I've seen worse I
in case of any f5 I got a square only
fire for my bishop my problem child is
this night only eight if I get this to a
decent square it might be okay here this
position at least them it's not like
terribly bad and here for be 5 f-5 is is
possible probably Bishop b5 still what I
want this I want to get in b5 this would
be would be nice
okay so he's a knowing
the straight
sorry for the noise has some big truck
Hot sands outside my apartment making
noises okay so i tried to what i said my
problem p is once you get it to c5 the
the issue might be f5 simply attacking
oh that i did not expect the straight
check
how do I play here
Quincy five is setting up a pin I don't
know maybe still might be forms no I
don't have night c 2 mm that's bad maybe
here four is six or five yeah okay use
Excel no no I can go if five or not hmm
and not really but anyway if he goes f6
i have e 5 thats it's okay i guess i can
go be 56 I can also just take okay
what you five chicks and we can if he
takes on pants all night takes my rook
is also hanging and I can do that though
it's not not really not getting
checkmated quickly here because of the
the pinning situation okay morning
nights if night here right
check Jim this night is not the best
piece of them I mean it's just wrong
then it's wrong on b5 and would be nice
on c5 but I don't get it down home
I don't see away from how this night to
to get on a good square him ah what a
shame I don't think this was a bad
position at all now it is to just
terrible okay yeah I played that
probably quite black quite a quite
strong way yeah just a terrible position
I have no time it's a bit early to
resign but I mean around here I've never
worse I don't think so check after this
year cannot believe that but it is some
probably it is difficult and he played
it well I guess so what is the right
move b5 is good or f6 now I didn't think
of that one but if six air does make
some sense it's kind of a preemptive
strike threatening ft x g5 now I didn't
think of that one but it was my move so
bad okay you had the problem is i will I
was kind of I was thinking when I went
here that he should do a five and the
computer says I'm clearly better after
that so what the mmm beep I am you know
what i did not see at orders I'm
threatening g5 was check yet so that's
so bad i was i was thinking of thinking
okay well my rook is hanging and so on
well that's completely irrelevant here
of course and so I thought you would
just move his rook back and then i have
a problem yeah but i can just take here
yes and that's just terrible I I was
always thinking that just from a
positional point of view this would be
very nice if he moves the rock I'm just
clearly better and so he has to take i
mean this is this is I can even Queens
it was possible but I was thinking that
just just checking this is very nice if
I get night on c5
here is this kind of thing but okay I
totally did not see that here that g5 is
hanging with a check so this was this
was how he how he got into this good
position by allowing something that I
did not see okay yeah because I care
here still okay but okay the problem was
that that hear this well after night be
5 i'm just in a in a very bad spot I
have to do something else but I couldn't
find something good here it seems look
FB 8 is still good this and queenly 6
hmm and I wonder why this is still ok
why it's very computer computer ish 98
for this for this tactic here
the engine is just saying equal that's
very difficult to to play I mean this is
very difficult to play and find find
yeah this is a problem value sometimes
you have those positions where I mean
you're probably okay or or sometimes
even better but it's it's difficult to
play if you're here if they give you if
you give the engine some time it
actually comes up with that and since
black is own is in a very good shape
it's very difficult to play those some
does this very precisely with one minute
on the clock it's may be easier for
white and so he did a good job here with
Roxy one yeah and now I'm under that
pressure that I went with this and this
is just really bad check this is just a
really bad position okay resigning is
early but I were 20 seconds and I didn't
see a move the computer justice is on
1.2 yeah okay it's not like you can none
that you need to resign but I mean what
is the comp giving actually a 3 b3 h5
yeah that was kind of okay what else
moves and somewhere here or what and
then what what is exactly how i can go
here what is my plan exactly so we're
thinking before it's very annoying if i
go here this this is actually not so
clear going to the engine that looks
terrible this with this with this weird
pinned night you just as equal cannot
believe that okay I'm threatening rook
takes e4 in some positions
hard to understand how to understand
okay well thanks for watching